a day after overseas travel started
getting back to normal aaa is predicting
a sharp rebound in thanksgiving travel
in fact to near pre-pandemic levels
think about that more than 53 million
americans are expected to travel over
that holiday weekend and it follows a
day of happy reunions yesterday after
the u.s ended pandemic travel
restrictions affecting more than 30
countries love those reunion pictures
errol barnett is at charlotte douglas
international airport for us errol good
morning
hey there tony good morning i love the
reunions too and the fact is those
seeking joy this thanksgiving will
likely have to go through some type of
journey first and yes it will be a
crowded one roads will be jam-packed
airports like this one will be busy
especially when you consider the tsa had
only 60 of staff with a single dose last
month the deadline is less than two
weeks away that plus borders reopening
to foreign national means a holiday
crunch like no other
families here in the u.s and across the
globe will be making up for lost time
this holiday season
since they last saw harper
she's grown up so much later this month
the hathaway nichols family in olympia
washington will be flying to ohio to
visit relatives they haven't seen in two
years it's like a
five and a half different person and and
just lost her tooth
and
yeah there's just a lot of different
things and life events that have gone on
they will be among the more than 53
million people expected to travel over
the thanksgiving holiday and despite gas
prices inching up more than a dollar a
gallon since last year ninety percent of
travelers are expected to drive
aaa says plan ahead you're going to be
driving on crowded roads there's going
to be traffic
they're going to be lines at the airport
be patient
this comes as the u.s lifted a 33
country travel ban monday
this was the moment bhavna patel saw her
grandson for the first time
yeah
after landing in new york from london
how do you describe this feeling
you know
yeah look
it's such a joy you know
yes yes
yes
it's all just so cute now look with
monday's reopening of u.s borders it
seems to have gone smoothly but aaa is
providing some advice for those of you
who are planning to travel for
thanksgiving to keep things smooth they
say book early morning flights because
those are the ones less likely to be
cancelled or delayed also if you're
gonna drive thanksgiving drivers should
consider heading out early leaving
either wednesday uh before noon or
thursday morning if you're not traveling
too far the point here is plan now uh
nate to save on all that stress later
that's right and it's fitting you're at
the airport because errol you always
look fly thank you